multiplica y simplifica x al cuadrado
menos raíz de 6 por x al cuadrado más
raíz de dos o sea nos piden multiplicar
dos polinomios de dos términos vaya a
multiplicar dos binomios hay varias
formas de hacer esto en este vídeo vamos
a ver dos una es una forma intuitiva que
nada más utiliza la propiedad
distributiva de la suma con la
multiplicación y la otra es una forma
que se ve en clase que es un poquito más
rápida pero requiere un poquito de
memoria bueno vamos a empezar con la
forma intuitiva y para esto déjame poner
aquí la ley distributiva a por x + es
igual a a x a x más ay estoy aquí es la
distributiva de la multiplicación con la
suma vale ok entonces vamos a usar esto
acá pero pensando que x cuadrada menos 6
es nuestra a es como nuestra entonces
vamos a distribuir la en estos dos
numeritos de aquí déjame ver que nos
queda saber x cuadrada menos 6 lo
tenemos que poner acá
x cuadrada menos raíz de 6 perdón menos
raíz de 6 va aquí eso tenemos que
multiplicarlo por x al cuadrado y
tenemos que sumar esto puede ser un poco
quizás no tan intuitivo porque esta es
una expresión grande verdad pero es
igualito que acá simplemente la pensamos
como a y lo distribuimos así entonces
sería más que eso mismo x cuadrada menos
raíz de 6
por el segundo término que es raíz de 2
raíz de dos muy bien ahora la parte
padre es que nada más tenemos que usar
distributiva that otra vez cómo le
hacemos ahora ahora lo que nos gustaría
es distribuir este x al cuadrado en
estos dos términos y este raíz de dos en
estos dos términos vaya estamos usando
la distributiva y that pero ahora sí
como x más por a es igual a a x más a ye
nada más estamos cambiando el orden de
la operación así que no pasa nada vale
entonces vamos a distribuir así y vamos
a ver que nos queda entonces x al
cuadrado por x al cuadrado es x a la
cuarta x a la cuarta luego x al cuadrado
por menos raíz de 6 es menos raíz de 6x
cuadrada luego raíz de 2 por equis
cuadrada es más raíz de 2 x al cuadrado
y luego sería menos raíz de 2 x raíz de
6 déjame hacerlo por aquí por separado
para que quede más bonito raíz de 2 x
raíz de 6 es igual a esto es lo mismo
que raíz de 2 por 6 que es igual a raíz
de 12 vale esto es utilizando
propiedades de los radicales
entonces nos queda menos menos raíz de
12 ok ya con esto logramos multiplicar
ahora hay que simplificar vale entonces
para simplificar pues tenemos este x a
la cuarta y la cuarta que no hay ningún
otro término de grado 4 entonces se
queda solito luego tenemos que juntar
estos dos tenemos que ponerle por acá y
aquí le voy a poner sin más y aquí voy a
abrir paréntesis x cuadrada entonces que
nos quedaría aquí adentro ya raíz de dos
menos raíz de 6
otra vez aquí estamos aprovechando la
propiedad distributiva verdad si
multiplicas te vuelve a quedar lo de
aquí arriba y finalmente pues podríamos
simplificar este raíz de 12 de la
siguiente forma raíz de 12 también es
igual a raíz de 3
por 4 que es raíz de 3 por raíz de 4 que
es igual a dos veces raíz de 3 porque
raíz de 4 es igual a 2 entonces podemos
poner este raíz de 12 como menos dos
veces raíz de 3 muy bien bueno de hecho
se puede argumentar o debatir si la de
arriba o la de abajo son más simples
pero bueno ya multiplicamos y
simplificamos utilizando únicamente la
propiedad distributiva vale no es nada
nuevo no es nada demasiado sofisticado
ahora déjame ver otro método que se
conoce como el método foil foil que
viene de sus siglas en inglés
first out bueno autor inner y last vamos
a ver de qué se trata este método
básicamente es un algoritmo a mí no me
gusta mucho no soy muy fan porque
favorece la memorización en vez de
entender una idea simple que la
propiedad distributiva pero bueno al
menos el método foil si se asegura de
que multiplicamos todo lo que hay que
multiplicar y la idea es la siguiente la
idea es la f quiere decir first o sea
los primeros términos tenemos que
aplicar este con este entonces lo
ponemos x cuadrada por equis cuadradas x
4 va luego o es de autor tenemos que
multiplicar los de afuera cuáles son los
que quedan afuera pues serían este x
cuadrada con este raíz de 2 entonces esa
es la o sería más más raíz de 2 x
cuadradas raíz de 2 x cuadrada luego y
sería de giner o sea los que están
adentro giner viene del inglés como
adentro entonces tendríamos que
multiplicar estos dos deja de tomar el
color amarillo digamos entonces estos
dos hay que multiplicarlos nos quedaría
menos raíz de 6 x al cuadrado esta de
ahí es la ahí y finalmente con color
rojo voy a hacer la l que quiere decir
las los últimos términos o sea este es
el último de aquí y este es el último de
acá entonces tenemos que multiplicar
esos dos quizás debía haber marcado el
amarillo también bueno entonces los
rojos son los últimos dos que es menos
raíz de 6 x raíz de 2 que ya vimos acá
arriba que es menos
a raíz de 12 y si te das cuenta que da
exactamente lo mismo que acá verdad
bueno estos dos quedan cambiados pero es
exactamente la misma expresión y por lo
tanto después de eso ya puedes
simplificar la a esta expresión que ya
encontramos entonces está bien usarlo y
también te da la respuesta correcta pero
hay que tener en cuenta que este método
que es un algoritmo simplemente viene de
aplicar la propiedad distributiva dos
veces